durant trois semaines j'ai arpenté les
montagnes la jungle et la côte
colombienne à la recherche des saveurs
locales mais aussi des paysages
incroyables que ce pays détient des
grains de l'arabica de la zone à café
terrain auquel sitôt asadho du désert en
passant par le poisson plis du bord de
la région de choco voici mon road trip
en colon tellement au principal ce matin
l'amour dans la cuisine
malgré sa réputation sulfureuse mais
jean est une ville très sécurisé et
agréable à visiter
anciennement obtenus par les guérilleros
les farc ou encore le hélène la commune
intéressée est désormais un quartier
touristique où les murs se transforme en
musée à ciel ouvert dans la zone
d'immeubles à dos les restaurants
terrasses rooftop et bars fleurissent à
chaque coin de rue
[Musique]
mon voyage culinaire commence lui par la
minorité
un gigantesque marché inauguré en 1984
trente quatre mille mètres carrés
s'offrent aux habitants et voyageur
curieux sur les quelques 8000
commerçants qui travaillent
nous sommes allés rencontrer en derrière
qui tient la tienne d'assises n'ont pour
seul andré acquis en faire goûter et au
matériel volé ce rayon pourri d'augusto
des tomates et et on a compris tout
comme la goyave à kourou christophe
moreau hippolyte au matin
moyens sinon on va voir ce que ça
donnera un prix très assir s'accroît
par exemple des toiles kiwi à c
on mange bien là bas il manque peu ou
beaucoup plus petit et traitant
pauvre
oui sûrement dit que c'est comme les
crottes de nez d'éléphants veut dire aux
micros de donner des bons comme un bruit
la passion mais beaucoup
agréable surprise toi tu en voilà non je
me paraît qu'un sac de mangues qui m'a
coûté deux mille pesos globalement de
1000 pesos ça fait cinquante sorties
je continue ma déambulation dans les
couloirs bondés de la minorité à la
recherche d'autres spécialités la région
donkey au cas où se situe mais des jeans
et surtout connu pour ses arrêts face
des galettes de maïs fraîche grillées au
feu de bois et je me dis que si je
mangeais 7 arrivera ce gel et on est
tombé amoureux de la cuisine r c'est ce
qu'on va vérifier je vais goûter cet
arrêt par votre chocolat
un régal locale qui s'accompagne d'un
fromage frais de vaches et de beurre
salé
alors s'il ya beaucoup de peur aux sept
ans qu'à emporter en réjoui plus d'un
sur le marché c'est seulement à quelques
mètres de là que l'on peut découvrir les
secrets de fabrication de ces galettes
que l'on mange à toutes heures
[Musique]
campagne
changement de décor en seulement 45
minutes
nous arrivons dans la région d'el choco
un bout de jungle sauvage face à la mer
[Musique]
tous
oubliez les routes ici tout se fait en
bateau les touristes ont disparu et le
poisson est fraîchement pêchés
ici les restaurants sont rares et c'est
chez l'habitant qu'il faut aller dîner
accurso caisse pas taccone si ce bébé
[Musique]
les pâtes akon ces galettes de plantain
frites sont très réputés dans tout le
pays
après nous être égalé la veille nous
essayons d'en cuisine et quelques-unes
et on sera pas déçu
[Musique]
on se dirige ensuite vers la zone à café
telle une région montagneuse à 200 km au
sud de medellin colombie
très montagneux on est en train de se
dire il
alors ça les moutons
il faut compter six heures faire
seulement 150 villeray
[Musique]
géographie du sol conditions
météorologiques tous les éléments sont
réunis pour permettre à l'arabica de
fleurir et d'offrir un café goûtu avec
du corps nous allons donc visité une
finca une ferme de café pas comme les et
des rockets face à des familles et jeu
on est dans la finca de john elias c'est
un octogénaire dont qui tient une finca
c'est une zone où on fait pousser du
café depuis maintenant plus de trente
ans il a donc quatre hectares qui sont
uniquement dédié à une agriculture
biologique et l'on est en train de faire
un tour avec son petit-fils qui nous
expliquent comment ils font avec la
permaculture avec les autres plantes
pour faire pousser du café sans utiliser
de pesticides
je voulais suivre et la vie à dieu amour
pour clôturer la méta la section locale
ok cool occasionna escanaux élimine une
élimination en quarts est aussi
différente et plagas insectes transmises
par l olp at chez ma soeur rapide et
assez banal l'analyse est quoi
lorsque nous explique matteo depuis tout
est là c'est que toutes ces techniques
de permaculture elles sont que possible
parce qu'il n'ya 4 ha c'est tout petit
une ferme de café ça peut aller jusqu'à
200 hectares donc là ils peuvent se
permettre d'avoir ces techniques avec
les bananes le piment et les autres
plantes qui sont autour mais c'est parce
que la ferme est vraiment tout petit
moins facilement des poèmes aux bagnards
l'un l'autre à trappes a questionné la
hauteur car elle perd gamine
106 bergon l'heure de la dégustation
maintenant qu'on a ramassé les grains de
café qu'on les a pelé l'avc hischier
toaster et enfin mixer on peut y
déguster
ils pensent tous
[Musique]
oh
après ces escapades montagneuses et
maritime nous choisissons une région
bien plus arides au sud de la colombie
bienvenue dans l tessières données data
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc ça ces petits fruits s'appelle la
thonaille origo comme on n'en fait plus
beaucoup d'eau en plus manger petits
fruits c'est à l'intérieur c'est comme
un fruit du dragon de petit grain bain
noir et une chaire pierre blanche
[Musique]
les partis ce matin très tôt il faisait
encore nuit
mais avant de partir du désert on a
profité pour acheter une spécialité
locale
alors ça s'appelle criscito asadho fait
un fromage cidriers voilà hégelé ont
fait son appel de l'arrêt qui paie la
région de sa chef
voilà j'en suis assez fan c'est une
sorte de ces du dulce des letchis au
fait c'est la confiture de lait non dans
le désert ils mangent ce fromage
typiquement avec du double cd laitiers
et donc c'est ce qu'on va faire
ce matin avant de reprendre le bus pour
9 heures un petit morceau de fromage ait
dû le céder les ché tout ça fait au
milieu du désert à consommer emporté sur
la route avant de prendre le bus up ou
après une longue journée de bus on vient
enfin d'arriver à popayan popayan c'est
une ville coloniale qui a été bâti au
xvième siècle par un conquistador
espagnol
alors s'il est réputé par la finesse de
son art religieux ces intellectuels ou
encore son université
c'est sa culture culinaire qu'on est
venu découvrir ici puisque en 2005 elle
a remporté le titre de ville la plus
créative de la gastronomie
selon l'unesco c'est ce qu'on va
vérifier tout de suite
[Musique]
largement cuisine et dans toute
l'amérique du sud
l'esmt ennahda se consomme au coin de la
rue sur une chaise en plastique ou en
marchant à pau bayonne
il existe une recette emblématique de la
ville le pipi yann et ses déclarations
déjà en train de se battre entre eux dit
reprenant c'est la merde c'est la
meilleure pour savoir qui va donner le
coureur de cuisine à ross est le secret
de la patte derrière le big dance est
donc un mélange de pommes de terre ou
des pistes de ses boys ados d'oignons et
d'ail
on comprend la pâte c'est grâce comme un
tout petit peu on le repli
la recette secrète dont des meilleurs
hommes pena d'as de toute la colombie
comme c'est ici ni des empanadas de fip
ian pas
je sais pas si on pourra vendre les
images encore fermé récemment
[Musique]
plus de mille âmes benhadda par jour ici
sur cette petite table c'est une chose
qui est fait à base de larry larry c'est
un pays émergent avec akon manie donc
avec une sauce un peu cacahuètes c'est
un peu la dass
donc ils sont sont végétariens france
crime et la viande de dans un petit peu
du tout mais après ça ça coûte 250 pesos
tafer
un peu moins de sentiments
alors si les empanadas de pipi yann sont
une des spécialités très connu et c'est
que le pipeline nous cette recette cette
préparation à base de pommes de terre
n'ont fait aussi une autre recette
s'amène le tas malaise de pipelines et
c'est ce qu'on va les voir dans un autre
restaurant
à aider veut nous apprendre comment
faire l'état malaise dont clytemnestre
ça comme banana cola la ola dans nos
colonnes qu'il convient de mettre donc
au poids temps de 10 minutes même si la
pâte est déjà pris cuite ont le courant
y en a tant à idées nous fait goûter la
pâte de cacahuète qu'elle prépare et
utilise pour la sauce qui accompagnent
les mp dans huit poules ont ils volé de
les peler les toasts et et les écraser
voilà enfin on fait ça avec des mecs du
harry du piment et ça fait la petite
sauce c'est bien l'idée c'est que ici ça
n'a pas mangé après la dass ici en fait
on n'a pas voté les mp d'ânesse de ses
clients simplement on a goûté la recette
de thomas leys et les fameux
les meilleurs alors là pour le coup la
source de sécurité avait quand même plus
fine que ça qu'on a goûté au tchad grâce
à idées impossible de passer dans la
région d'el kaoka sans une escale à cali
la caliente capitales mondiales auto
déclarées et reconnues de la salsa
[Musique]
les colombiens sont connus pour être de
bons carnivores on trouve de la viande à
chaque coin de rue comme ce fumoir chez
elle barils on peut choisir du port ou
du boeuf qui a deux parties du boeuf
c'est soit la côte soit ici la poitrine
il en fait grâce bien car à miser
extérieur en bien fondante à l'intérieur
avec des vraiment des beaux morceaux de
gras qui ont bien nourris n'avions donc
220 grammes de viande on en a eu beau
douze mille pesos ici fait environ 4
euros
de quoi ravir de nombreux carnivores
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fidèle au poste nous enchaînons avec un
autre restaurant mais d'une autre gamme
celle de la cuisine d'auteur chez zumaya
la culture sud américaine est très
gourmande heures en termes de ceviche
est donc ici on est venus déguster du
poisson frais et cru bon en l'occurrence
ici l'homme le polype été légèrement
grillées avec une sauce à l'ail et
purée de carottes en tout cas ça fait
plaisir pour le feu
baby qui vont déguster des plats toute
la journée le ventre bien rempli
il est temps de travailler nos pas de
danse dans une institution de la salsa
la tomate hollande
[Musique]
retour à la case départ après plus de
deux semaines de vadrouille nous
remontons vers médecine on va vivre une
expérience un petit peu différente
puisque pendant quatre jours on va être
dans un ashram donc c'est un centre de
yoga avec une cuisine uniquement
végétarienne ils ont des produits locaux
avec un potage également donc cette
l'occasion des quelque chose d'un petit
peu différent
[Musique]
il est même pas encore 6 heures du matin
on se trouve dans le réseau donc c'est
là où il stocke tous les légumes dans
ces boîtes ici vous allez grémy les
épices et tout ce qu'il faut pour manger
et on a préparé le bond du matin donc si
un pain avec de la farine complète de la
farine intégrale des graines de lin
quelques chromes de riz de la nouvelle
évidemment
ensuite on va le faire qu'on fait
c'est parti pour la séquence matinale
avec cathy qui fait partie de l'équipe
du matin le bien-être
[Musique]
ça c'est récolte deux octaves du potager
et qui à la salade d'herbes aromatiques
sauterelles dessus du bouquin ça c'est
de la goana ban à sa super fruits
ensuite il ya quelques temps
c'est une spécialité locale et le cacao
s'est activée connaît la lpcc après la
première qui est la médecine el corazon
s'est pas coupé un peu du camp
l'idée c'est de faire des petits
morceaux des petits cubes comme ça
qu'ils auront ensuite dans le dans le
curry de légumes
je découvre anges de la vuelta qui
viennent donc tout ça ça vient en plus
du potager ils sont en train de faire
suer c'est avec un petit peu de coco
râpée du curry et et du gingembre des
congés tôt de wayne tha tout ça ça vient
donc du jardin ça a été a été ramassé ce
matin voilà c'est le périple comme
cassina et les maraudes à se démarquer
et à ceux qui me tourmente par des
fixeurs commenté
c'est fou hein samarie les poneys ta
console à l'espace haciendo laitiers
étaient ces milieux s'est dit d'accord
on connaîtra ses mille prix mais lol la
touriste ont pas leur place pour ce soit
par la surface italienne de la colonne
entre la voix et au sénat les cours
ouais c'est ce qu'ils appellent le
fromage vegan et que prenait d'espèces
elle y est basse et aya dressé contre ma
thèse ces gosses étaient en mode eco et
la cuisine créative dans l'ashram chacun
apporte sa petite touche s'aggraverait
le pain est enfin prêt c'est une odeur
de dengue se sont super bons tout légume
les salades
la soupe est prête le
curry de légumes avec du chou fleur la
salade est prête il ya des choses qui
sont terminées le dressage également un
petit peu de fromage un petit peu de
confiture et dulce des déchets pour les
personnes qui sont aussi grandes et puis
on va pouvoir manger dans quelques
minutes avec tous les jus et tous les
laits végétaux qui ont été préparés
aussi pendant un batik
[Musique]
bon ça serait vous mentir de vous dire
que je n'ai pas goûté les plats avant
tout cas tout est très bon fromage le
végétal nouveau avec des restes des
amendes qui ont été mixés de tournesol
pour faire le lait le très bon et le
pain le riz le chou-fleur la soupe juke
est ce que tu en penses
j'ai fait avec beaucoup d'amour fois que
cela était tellement au principal ce
matin l'amour dans la cuisine
[Musique]